[Applause]
what you're seeing isn't a watercolor
painting in motion in fact it's the
planet Jupiter for the most part this
gas giant is a mystery so what would
happen if you wanted to discover it for
yourself and jumped right onto the
planet or should we say into because
Jupiter doesn't have a surface just a
seemingly endless stretch of atmosphere
would you fall straight through what
would you see on your way and how would
it make you feel this is what if and
here's what would happen if you fell
into Jupiter if you attempt it to jump
into Jupiter wearing a standard space
suit it would be over for you pretty
quickly first of all you wouldn't even
make it to the planet roughly three
hundred thousand kilometres from Jupiter
radiation would penetrate your suit and
you die but that's a boring what-if
we'll give you a special spacesuit that
can survive the fall for now here's
where the real fun begins at first
you'll be falling from the top of the
atmosphere at nearly 180,000 kilometres
per hour
that's a lot faster than you'd fall from
the top of Earth's atmosphere because
Jupiter's gravity is much stronger than
Earth's you'd still be able to see the
Sun but don't expect it to heat you up
at about 250 kilometers down you've
reached the ammonia clouds and
experienced temperatures of minus 150
degrees now get ready for the most epic
whirlpool of your life Jupiter's clouds
create powerful winds up to 482 km/h
you'd feel as if you were in one giant
colourful tornado that's because Jupiter
is the fastest rotating planet in our
solar system one day on the planet is
equal to nine and a half earth hours
let's go down about 120 kilometers more
congratulations this is the deepest that
any exploration has ever sailed into the
gas giant in 1995 NASA's Galileo probe
made it this far before it was destroyed
by the pressure of Jupiter's atmosphere
but don't worry that's not happening to
you you've
the suit the further you travel the
darker it will get until it's completely
pitch black the only source of light
you'll have will be from the lightning
storms happening all around you at this
point the temperature will start to
increase and it might even feel
comfortable if it weren't for the
immense physical pressure you'll be
feeling the pressure you'd experience is
more than 1,000 times higher than on the
surface of the earth the only way you'll
be able to survive is if your space suit
was built as strong as the deepest
diving submarine of all time by now
you've been falling for 12 hours and
let's be honest you're getting a little
bored you'd probably want a radio
someone to come and get you well that's
too bad that's an impossibility inside
Jupiter
since radio waves get absorbed this deep
into the planet's atmosphere you'll just
have to keep falling
the temperature will keep rising and so
will the pressure as you reach the inner
layers of Jupiter there'll be parts that
you'll be able to swim through a
substance that's not quite liquid or gas
known as supercritical fluid moving
through the strange material the
temperature will get even hotter
eventually it will be equivalent to the
surface of the Sun if that isn't enough
you'll also be experiencing pressure
equal to 2 million times the pressure on
earth metallic hydrogen will begin to
form and you'll be surrounded by it this
relatively unknown substance can be a
dense liquid that you won't be able to
escape from if you do manage to escape
you'd be falling through it for
thousands of kilometres until you reach
due Pater's core possibly a solid object
some scientists predict it is due to the
immense pressure at this level in the
planet regardless of what it is if you
somehow did manage to survive all this
you'd be stuck on it from all the
atmospheric pressure not a very
rewarding trip maybe we should leave the
planet as a beautiful mystery but if you
do ever manage to fall into Jupiter and
get stuck let's hope you have a few more
what-if videos to keep you company
you
[Music]